But in Islam, they explain Jannah so
beautifully. Like that is just amazing.
>> My goodness. My goodness. My goodness.
Islamic Jannah.
[Music]
What's going on everybody? We're back
with another one. Got Chris of Dilemma's
Corner in here, the Islamic Dilemminator
and Giant DLC and yours truly the
Sheikh, Sheikh Dilemma. Look guys, so
here we got a so-called convert to Islam
or what they say they say revert. They
reverted to Islam cuz we all were
Muslims before. And she gives her three
reasons on why she converted to Islam
and why she's choosing Islam over
Christianity. So, when somebody gives
these type of reasons,
you would hope that they've, you know,
done their research and they're giving
legitimate objections to to to to one
side with knowledgeable based opinions,
right? And then therefore comparing the
two, she made a logical fair decision
that this is what makes sense. This is
what I found evidently true and this is
why I'm choosing Islam over
Christianity. That's that's what we
would hope to see. Is that right, fellas
and lady?
>> That's right. That's what we would hope
to see, but 100% of the time you watch
when you watch these videos, it is
always always always a bunch of Dawah
script nonsense. Like they'll say, "And
then I noticed this about Christianity
when I was a Christian." And it's just
Dawah script. It's not it's nothing
anyone would have ever noticed as a
Christian because it's fake. And it's
just Dawah script. And then but then I
found out Islam and then it's 100% Dawah
script nonsense. And this that's every
that's every video. And that's what
Muslims love. And it's just it's like
pretty sad.
>> it up. You can blow up off of that.
Let's go ahead and see what what she
what she lays out. We're going to see
the evidences that she gives and see why
it is that she picked Islam. Why I
reverted to Islam and I can never give
them a solid answer. So, I'm going to
give you guys three reasons of why I
reverted to Islam. She can never give a
solid answer why. I think that's
interesting. I think that's very
interesting. When people ask me why I
converted to Islam or reverted to Islam,
I can never give a solid answer. Maybe
you should reflect on that a little bit.
Maybe it's because there are no good
solid answers to give. But anyway, she's
going to try, so
>> That is a tough way to start off your
video.
The whole Holy Trinity thing is very
complicated, to say the least. Please
don't convert me. But to further explain
a little bit, how can God be one and
three at the same time? The math ain't
mathin'. How can God be one and three at
the same time? The math isn't mathing.
And then she goes on to give a
definition, I believe, of one God. Let's
see. Islam, there's only one God and one
God only. Allah is one. Monotheistic,
relating to or characterized by the
belief that there is only one God.
Period. You see her reading?
Now guys, does that sound like someone
who is interested in Christianity and
studying Christianity and was confused
and then just found out about Islam?
Does that sound like someone who was
programmed by the Dawah script and had
had no clue about anything in
Christianity or anything in Islam?
>> Programmed 100%, yeah. Bought the Dawah
script, held on to the Dawah script,
downloaded the Dawah script and then
start spouting the Dawah script.
>> Every single time. There are reasons
people leave Christianity and say and
maybe it's suffering, right? Or maybe
there are reasons that you can hear
people give when they leave
Christianity. I've never heard someone
say, and maybe this is just me, but I've
never heard someone say, "Hey Chris, you
know, I was sitting there just
reflecting on the Trinity one day and I
was like, one, three, it doesn't make
sense." Like I've never heard a
Christian ever say this because it's not
what Christians teach. And yet, funny
enough, it happens to align with the
Dawah script's misrepresentation of the
Trinity, which is really interesting how
they just line up like that.
>> I I just want to say so she says that
she left Christianity because of the
Trinity and she joined a religion that
doesn't understand the Trinity. So, the
Quran over and over and over again
misrepresents the doctrine of the
Trinity, defining the Trinity as Allah,
Jesus, and Mary. Now, I'm sure with her
education of Christianity, whatever it
was, that she knows that that's not the
Trinity. So, imagine this. You leave a
religion because of your
misunderstanding about God and then you
join a religion that misrepresents that
misunderstanding about God. According to
her, right?
>> Just to put it in all just short really
quick here. The Trinity is the concept
that there's one God, one divine essence
that consists of three distinct persons,
the Father, Son, and Holy Spirit, who
are co-equal, co-eternal, who have
always existed with each other in
perfect unity and fellowship from
eternities past, inseparable,
indivisible within their essence while
being distinct in their personhood.
That's what the Trinity is in a
nutshell. And so, if you're a Christian,
that's what you believe and you should
be able to know that going in if you're
going to be looking into Islam and and
saying that is you're choosing Islam
over Christianity. And and then also
saying that the Trinity doesn't go with
monotheism when that literally is what
the Trinity is. Yeah, and if you're just
going to erase categories and say one
and three, three and one, how can one be
three and three be one? And you're going
to ignore categorical differences that
Christians have always made that the one
is the one God and the three are the
three persons. And so, to reduce that to
just one and just three and act as if
those are the same things and that's
what we mean when we say one and three,
that's being dishonest. But you could do
the same thing with Islam, couldn't you?
Yeah, you could do the same thing with
Islam if you were being uncharitable
like she she is. We could be like
there's there's How can how can Allah be
one and and 99 at the same time? Uh the
99 attributes or names of Allah and we
can be unfair, uncharitable, and
dishonest and be like, "See, you guys
believe in 99 gods." Yeah, how can Allah
be 99 and one at the same time? And it's
it's very interesting because you'll
have these 99 names and they correspond
to 99 attributes. So, what's that mean?
If if Allah has 99 attributes, then in
in one sense he's one, he's one in
being, but he's more than one in
attribute. He's 99 in attribute. But it
I mean it it gets crazier because
Allah's attributes can actually be in
conflict with each other. Allah says
that his mercy triumphs over his wrath.
So, he has one attribute, wrath, that
calls for one thing. Then he has another
attribute, mercy, that calls for a
different sort of action and they're in
conflict and his mercy triumphs over his
wrath. That means he's got two different
attributes and they're in conflict with
each other and one of them wins over the
other. We wouldn't say therefore you
believe in multiple gods. So, just to be
clear, Allah can be one in one way, more
than one in another way, but that was
that was her only objection to the
Trinity. Well, how can God be one and
three? Well, how can Allah be one and 99
or one and, you know, with these
different attributes? And again, this is
this is what we're saying. It's standard
Dawah script nonsense that oh, the
Trinity was confusing, but in Islam,
Allah is so easy to understand. Yeah,
until you start getting down to his body
parts and his two right his two right
arms and his one leg with the two feet
on the bottom of it and all these
different things. And they never tell
them that. And they don't even tell they
don't even tell them that you have this
big dispute in Islam with whether these
are actual body parts, physical body
parts or not and that Muslims are
hopelessly confused over over this sort
of thing. But even like the basics you
get from from the Quran and the Hadith,
I mean think about the confusion if they
actually if you actually applied the
same reasoning and said, "Well, this is
really confusing." So, if you just take
what you the basics that you have in the
Quran and the Hadith, you've got Allah,
but Allah speaks out his word. He speaks
out his word. He speaks out his word,
which is Jesus, and he speaks out his
word, which is the Quran. But Muslims
believe that this has to be this is why
they say the Quran is eternal because
they can't believe that Allah changed
one day and then he started speaking.
So, speech has to be one of his
attributes. And so, Allah's always
speaking out the Quran. But the same the
exact same reasoning would apply to
Allah's spirit. Allah breathes out his
spirit. Now, when Allah creates
something, he just says be and it pops
into existence. His word, however,
originates from within him. He speaks it
out and his spirit he breathes out. So,
these are different kinds of things and
these are eternal. So, already you've
got Allah, his spirit, and his word. But
as we all know, his word actually
appears as a man and intercedes for
people. So, this is a and his spirit
appears as a man. So, you've got Allah
eternally breathing out his spirit who
is a personal agent. Allah from all
eternity is is speaking out his word who
is a personal agent who appears as a man
who intercedes for people and so on. So,
already you have three divine persons
from all eternity. But it gets worse
because Allah's speech that appears as a
man also appears as individual flocks of
birds. The chapters do. So, Sura two
appears as a flock of birds that
intercede and Sura three appears as a
flock of birds which intercede. If we
assume that this is true of all the
chapters of the Quran, not only certain
ones, then you've got Allah and his
speech appears as a man, his eternal
speech from all eternity. It appears as
a man, but within that one man are 114
flocks of birds who are also personal
agents and who intercede, who think, and
so on. So, the point is if you think the
Trinity is confusing, if you think the
Trinity is confusing, what are you doing
with this physical Allah with his with
his with his two right hands and so on
eternally breathing out a person, the
spirit, and eternally speaking out a
person, his word, and that one person
that one person is simultaneously 114
personal agents that appear as flocks of
birds to appear and intercede and they
communicate, they remember things, they
intercede. And it's just it's amazing
cuz it's a total parallel to the Allah
Al-Uzza and Manat that there were these
three goddesses who would intercede for
you. And Muhammad just replaces them
with chapters of the Quran that are
these bird goddesses that appear that
intercede for you. And it's just like,
"This is like insanely confusing." And
guess what? Do you think this woman has
any clue about any of that? When she was
doing all her research, do you think she
looked into any of that at all before
she decided, "Nope, Islam has got the
real simple God here." Mhm. Nope. Not
not one shred of research. Think about
what David just said, that Allah's mercy
can overcome his wrath. His mercy can
overcome his wrath. When the Quran is
dealing with Allah not having a son or
not existing alongside other gods in
chapter 23 verse 91, it says, "Never did
Allah take himself a son and never was
there with him any god. Otherwise, each
god would have certainly taken what he
has created and some of them would have
certainly overpowered others." Mhm. So,
think about this. Allah is refuting this
idea that he has a son or he exists
alongside other gods because if a son
were to exist, if other gods were to
exist, then they would overcome,
overpower each other. But, wait a
minute. Allah has that problem because
his mercy overcomes his wrath. So, he's
not getting out of this dilemma that
he's putting out. This is another
Islamic dilemma. Oh, wow. That's good.
That's so good. Well, that's reason
number one, guys. Let's go with reason
number two. Moving on to reason number
two is that the Quran has never been
altered. With Catholicism, they would
tell us that the reason why that the
Bible was constantly being altered and
changed is because times are changing.
Society is changing, which facts. But,
at the same time, the fact that it is
being altered so often and people are
putting their little inputs all the time
makes it that much more complicated. And
it also loses its credibility. It loses
its value. You get what I mean? And the
Quran, on the other hand, has never been
changed. The Quran has been the same
ever since it was revealed to us. And to
me, that's way more valuable and
credible.
So, Okay. Just to clarify Just to
clarify, guys,
so she's saying the Catholics are
talking about how the Bible's constantly
being changed and updated. They say,
"This is just to bring it in line with
modern time." You ever heard a Catholic
say that about the Bible? I've never.
You know what I think that means though?
I think cuz a lot of people they do this
thing where they think that a
translation is the same as a
transmission. So, they think "Oh,
there's all these English translations.
They must be different Bibles." And then
maybe hypothetically there was some
Catholic person that said, "That's
because these translations some are more
modern in modern English." And she
interpreted that to be, "Oh, this is
like because in modern times we just
make lots of Bibles." Or some weird
understanding.
>> That is the best explanation for what
Put it this way. Assuming she's not
completely making things up cuz my
assumption would have been she's just
completely making things up and she has
no clue what she's She's just She's just
making up the Dawah script. But, you're
pointing out, "Yeah, that that is the
only way that she wasn't just making
that up." If she was like, "What What
are all these different translations?"
And people are like, "Yeah, yeah, you
have to You have to keep translating and
stuff. Language changes and so on." And
then she thinks that's talking about
changing the Bible. But, but Chris, if
all she means is that, you know, as
language develops and so on that people
come up with different translations,
what doesn't that apply to the Quran as
well?
>> Exactly. Yeah, you can Sahih
International, Pickthall, Yusuf Ali.
What do you want? There are tons of
them. Yeah, and yeah, and they even try
to make like super easy to understand
versions. And they even like give like
completely ridiculous translations to
try and do away with problems and so on.
So,
Yeah, so if that's what you mean, lady,
then then you got the same problem with
the Quran. And if you don't think it's a
problem with the Quran, you shouldn't
have a problem with that being the
Bible. So, yeah, if she's if she thinks
the actual like text of the Hebrew and
Greek is constantly being changed and
upgraded, that's just nonsense that's
made up. But, I have to say, if it was
if it was if the Bible is constantly
being changed and updated as the Dawah
script would have you believe, then you
can't trust the Quran because the Quran
affirms the inspiration, the
preservation, and the authority of the
Torah and the Gospel. So, thank you,
ma'am, for attacking the Quran for us.
And just one real quick thing. You know,
she says the the Quran has never been
altered.
Islam is the only religion, as far as
I'm aware, that argues that actually we
altered our scriptures the best. We
altered the Quran in such a way that it
was totally faithful and what Allah
would have wanted. That's the I've never
heard another religion say that.
Christianity doesn't say that. Judaism
doesn't say that. But, Islam, no, they
were the best of alters. Allah is the
best of alters in your religion.
Uthman was sent and altered your Quran.
That's all I say about that. I'm still
in that. I'm about to use that in the
next stream. That's so good. I have to
wonder if the Quran has never been
changed, how do they have all these
different versions of the Quran today
which even contradict each other?
I mean, there are contradictions. So,
were the contradictions originally there
or they just developed later? If they
were there always, then the Quran is
just inherently contradictory. But, if
they came about later, then
what's she complaining about? It's a
good question. If you guys want to see
examples of these different Qurans,
myself, Jay, and DLC, we did a video on
five Quran variances that that everybody
should know. Pretty easy, contradictory
meaning changes. These aren't small
little differences. These are five Quran
variances that are easy to show a Muslim
how different the Qurans actually are.
So, you guys want to see that video,
that video is that link is going to be
in the description below. Go ahead and
click that and watch that. Take notes on
that, all right? So, let's move on to
point number three. And with that, I
love that the Quran is so open to
interpretation. She's completely 100%
correct. The Quran is open to
interpretation. Totally agree. Great
point. The miracle of reinterpretation.
I'll take You can literally make it say
anything you want. Just go to our Dawah,
guys. It doesn't matter what you like,
they'll say the Quran affirms it. The
Quran is like Play-Doh, basically. All
right. Point number three. Random, but
it is a huge reason as to why I actually
loved Islam in the beginning when I
first started learning about it. And
that is Jannah, heaven.
Hear me out. When I was Catholic, I
would literally lay at night thinking
about the fact that if I went to heaven,
I would have to live forever, terrified.
Because I feel like they never really
explained what heaven was like and how
beautiful it would be. But, in Islam,
they explain Jannah so beautifully and
makes you want to go to Jannah. You know
what I mean? The fact that we're going
to live forever sounds amazing. Fact
that the whole reason why we live and
come to this dunya is to go to Jannah.
And every detail about Jannah, for
example, the fact that you could bite an
apple and every bite is going to taste
different and better every time. Like
that is just amazing. I'm running out of
time, but I hope you guys enjoyed it and
I hope that made sense. I feel like I
was all over the place. But, you guys
My goodness. My goodness. My goodness.
Islamic Jannah. Yeah, yeah, let's just
clarify cuz guys did a Did she somehow
miss all of the relevant things
according to Islam about the afterlife
for women? Yes. She missed everything.
Every relevant thing when it came to the
women. We we know where the women are
going to be in the afterlife. Yeah.
Yeah, let me go let me go and quote a
couple passages here. First of all,
according to Muhammad, most of the
inhabitants of hell are women. I'll read
Bukhari right here. Muhammad said, "Oh,
women, give to charity, for I have seen
that the majority of the dwellers of
hellfire were women." The women asked,
"Oh,
Allah's apostle, what's the reason for
it?" He said, "Oh, women, you curse
frequently and are ungrateful to your
husbands. I have not seen anyone more
deficient in intelligence and religion
than you. Oh, women, some of you can
lead a cautious man astray." So, I don't
know why this this woman thinks that
she's bound to get into paradise if
she's a Muslim. I mean, even Muhammad
said he didn't know what Allah is going
to do with him. That same prophet said
most of the inhabitants of hell are
women because they're foolish and bad at
religion and ungrateful to their
husbands and so on. So, on the
assumption that she actually makes it,
is it going to be this "Oh, it's going
to be so awesome. It's going to be so
great." What actually happens? Whoever
your husband is, she'll have her husband
and he'll have either I guess if she's
lucky, she'll just he'll just have one
wife, but he can have multiple wives and
so on. In paradise, he will have all his
wives from earth, but he will also have
a bunch of additional specially designed
sex machines called houris that she'll
be competing with for all eternity for
her husband's her husband's attention.
So, I mean, just imagine she has like
this dream husband. She's like, "He's
the greatest man ever." Well, yeah, he's
going to have you, all his other wives,
and a bunch of houris, and you're going
to be What are you going to be doing?
I'll go and read it for you. This is
Bukhari. This is Bukhari. For some
reason, I'm guessing she missed this
somehow. Allah's apostle said, "In
paradise, there is a pavilion made of a
single hollow pearl 60 miles wide, in
each corner of which there are wives who
will not see those in the other corners,
and the believers will visit and enjoy
them." Lady, you're going to be standing
in a corner for all eternity and you're
not allowed to see or talk to women in
the other corners, and you just stand
there waiting for your husband to come
up and say, "All right, I'm ready for
sex." Problem is, your husband also has
these specially designed virgins that he
spends eternity deflowering. And after
he deflowers one of these virgins, Allah
miraculously restores her virginity
overnight so that she's a virgin again
the next day. And so, you'll be standing
in a corner for all eternity waiting for
your husband to pick you. And you'll be
sitting there going, "Pick me. Pick me.
Pick me." Yeah, that that should make
you want to convert. And just keep in
mind, by the way, she said that she was
terrified. That was the word she used.
Terrified of what Roman Catholics
believe about heaven.
Which if you think about it, like what
she thinking that they
If you're Roman Catholic and you go to
heaven, it's like, you know, like some
terrifying like scene of darkness and
like thunder. You're burning. You're
burning in the Roman those darn
Catholics What What What What did What
did she say about Christianity or Islam
that is within a trillion miles of being
correct? Nothing, man. Either she's
incredibly ignorant or this is just
straight out of a Dawah script. And
given that she knows nothing about what
Islam teaches for women, I'm thinking
this is a Dawah script. But, you know,
they did tell her about the amazing
power of apples and how delicious they
are, you know. But, but remember, guys,
this is what I was saying earlier that
her not knowing about the Trinity or the
persons in the Trinity, going to the
Quran and, you know, "Oh, yeah, it's
it's, you know, all all Jesus and Mary."
Her not knowing that, this is the she
doesn't even know what heaven is in
Christianity. She thinks it's some
terrifying place that used to keep her
up at night. Like, stop stop it. Cut it
out. But, this is what I'm saying. That
she she couldn't She didn't even know
what the Christian heaven is like. How
in the world is she going to
have any idea about the Trinity,
anything about the Trinity? The persons,
the the the the nature of God, anything
like that. Nothing.
>> Yeah, all all I'm saying is
it it would be one thing if this wasn't
standard. If this were like the
exception, but it's always the case.
It's "Hey, I didn't know anything about
Christianity. I didn't know about God in
Christianity. I didn't know anything
about the Bible. I thought the
translations meanings that they're
updating the Bible constantly and so on.
And I don't know how translations work
in Islam. I know nothing about God in
Christianity. I know nothing about the
Bible. I know nothing about God in
Islam.
I know nothing about the Quran. And a
Dawah guy came along, took advantage of
me, said a bunch of stuff, and I was too
completely ignorant of everything to
know any better. And now, now they're
using me to recruit to recruit more
young women and tell them how great
Islam is. Why? Because as Muhammad hijab
said, the revert women take it women.
They want women who are completely
ignorant so they can program them to do
whatever they want.
>> being said, guys, uh just want to leave
this off with an encouraging note. If
this is If you ever see this video or to
any of you guys who are thinking of
becoming Muslim, uh please watch this
video. And make sure that you actually
look into the claims of Islam, look into
the claims of Christianity, and and
check yourself. Do some self-reflection
before you start claiming that you left
Christianity when you never really was a
Christian. Like, look into it. Look into
what does it teach about the Trinity?
What really is it? What is the Bible?
What what what What are the facts about
the Bible? How did it come about? What
is the the heaven that's described in
the Bible? Just read Revelation 21, 22,
Revelation 7. Just open up the Bible and
just read it for once. And I hope that
this has encouraged you not to sit in
your ignorance and then make a video
exposing it.
>> If you read what the Bible says about
heaven, you will not be impressed by an
apple.
>> Just really quick, uh where will the
women be according to Muhammad in Islam?
They will be in tents in paradise
waiting for the men to come and you you
know what.
>> Mhm. Got it. So, you'll be in So, either
they got they got two things. They're
They're either going to be in hell,
which is the majority of them like
Muhammad says, or they're going to if
they make it to paradise, they're going
to be a pick me. They're going to be an
object of sexual pleasure. Welcome to
Islam, ladies and gentlemen. Make sure
you guys hit the like button, subscribe,
and make sure you comment down below,
and stay tuned for the next one. We'll
see you there.
Oh my god. Logic.